[Music]
Cheers. Cheers.
All right, welcome. My name is Trey
Blandon with Lucario Deluxe Media. I'm
here with Raymond Dbra. We have a lot of
to talk about tonight. The most
important uh central theme of it though
is masculinity, the role it plays in uh
the Christian life, right? So, we're
going to start with the most important
topic when it comes down to masculinity
is Raymond. People are dying to know
what's your workout routine.
They are actually I get a lot of
comments uh from people u on the on
YouTube and etc etc and I've you know
I've been meaning to actually like make
a whole dedicated video to it but you
know what why not talk about it now. Ah,
it goes way back, man. Back to when I
was uh a teenager. Started lifting
weights. Just was all into it and then
but I wanted to always I had a kind of
competitive thing. So, I wanted I you
know I wanted the weightlifting to lead
to something. So, I actually uh got into
football in high school. Yeah. So, what
position you play? Well, initially they
they had me as a defensive nose guard.
So they would just put me in the center
to create havoc
cuz I was, you know, when I was 17, I
was about the same height and I weighed
about 230 and I was pretty fast. So
Well, it's nice that you mellowed since
then. You no longer cause havoc anywhere
with anybody. No, I still do. But but
anyway, long story short, I
unfortunately uh injured myself, had an
ACL tear in my knees. Actually, I
remember back then I had a stack of
letters from colleges that wanted to
recruit me and that's what it was going
to be. But anyway, so the knee thing
happened, but I still wanted to lift
weights. I still liked lifting weights
and I had to find but again I wanted
some outlet and I gravitated to
bodybuilding.
I couldn't be a powerlifter. I couldn't
be an Olympic lifter. I didn't have that
kind of strength, my tendons and I I
tear a lot of things over the years, but
I got into bodybuilding and
competitively and I I actually won the
Mr. LA Teenage Division when I was 19.
And uh my last show actually I was uh 22
and it was I think called a tournament
or night of champions NPC. And what's
funny about that one is one of the guys
that I competed against who won the guy
who won it became Mr. Olympia. Oh wow.
Yeah. Jay Cutler. Okay. Awesome. But I
didn't really care for the bodybuilding
lifestyle. I just wanted to lift
weights. But didn't I didn't care for
the speed of
or you know having to shave your body
and all that sort of get that massive
tan that just looks so fake. So I just
at that point I I just stayed with the
weightlifting from that point on. So you
know I've been lifting weights uh 52
almost like 40 years honestly because I
started very young like maybe 13 with my
little joiner dumbbell. So with the um
bodybuilding aspect of weightlifting is
there a particular body part you focus
on or is it full body? No I do uh well
now everything's changed for me as I'm
older because I've had a lot of really
serious injuries. muscle tears,
ligaments, tendon tears. Um, so now and
I still love to lift heavy and uh it's
it's but I try to like tell myself, calm
down. You know, you're you're older.
Your healing process doesn't I had a
really bad tricep tear and I had surgery
and it's still completely, you know, it
didn't take. So this arm is even when I
lift weights, people come up to me and
like, "Hey, the right side has less
weights. You forgot to put an extra
plate." And I'm like, "No, that's how it
is." So anyway, I still kind of lift
heavy, but I try to, you know, keep it
slow and nothing too jerkish motions
because I don't want to tear anything.
Um, but yeah, I actually I think
weightlifting is a great thing. I think
people men should be involved in some
kind of physical athletic. It doesn't
have to be weightlifting. You don't have
to be muscle bound. I don't believe in
that, but that's just what I do and what
I like. I also bike a lot. You know, I
bike like, you know, last month I
clocked in at 450 miles. Nice. Yeah.
It's like my morning routine is how I
wake up and you know rejuvenate myself.
Yeah. So, um but I I I think guys need
to all do some kind of activity whether
it's jogging or you know swimming
whatever it's it's good being set and
the problem is with me you know my the
nature of my job is very sedentary.
I spend about eight hours in a recliner
chair with my laptop. So you've never
been one of those where guys where you
have the treadmill in front of your
computer.
Uh there's a time for I don't multitask
like that. Um so yeah, that's just been
my thing. I like to um you know, I like
to I I believe in balance, you know. Oh,
that's fair. But I think ty going off of
what you said, I think everybody, every
man should have a physical hobby, a
mental hobby, and a spiritual hobby or
if you don't want to use the word hobby
with spirituality, you know, something
that you do that, you know, forms
yourself and, you know, by over the
sizing of one over the other and that's,
you know, where you tend to fall out and
balance in your life. Perfectly agree.
and uh and you know I don't want to I
don't want to be an academic scholar who
just sits at home and you know like
armchair historian either but I and I
don't want to be a muscle bound you know
fool who doesn't know how to read either
so it's like yeah a good equilibrium I
think is very healthy and it's kind of
lacking amongst men today and so yeah I
think uh I'm going to start talking more
about my workout routine eventually and
kind of elaborating and kind of like how
to how to fix it how to fit it in with
everything else as it's and don't do it
for vain reasons, you know, like for me,
it's not about I want to look a certain
way. It's more the challenge, you know,
and and the actual intense.
I'll put it this way. When I bike, I
look forward to that. That's fun. I
dread the gym.
I like those the days I go and I only
work out twice a week. Okay. Yeah. I
only lift weights twice a week at this
point. And um but when I just just going
there, you know, my stomach I have it's
not enough cuz I know what I'm going to
go through is going to be painful.
Whereas biking is just fun. Low
intensity. Yeah, for me my injury
inducer thing was Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and boxing, just the shoulders,
and so that's gotten tougher as I've
gotten older to be able to stick with
that. But like you, for me, it was
always a matter of, you know, okay, I
like to compete, but I don't want to be
one of those that makes a a sport out of
it competing or get obsessed and become
like narcissistic about it. Because for
me it was always a matter of I want to
be able to protect people. You know as
you know my experiences in going to
places like Artock which was under uh
threat by Azob has finally taken over
and it's one of those things that if
they had started up something while I
was there would I be able to take care
of my neighbors who I was living. It's a
it's a real necessity for a man to be
able to you know just have be able to
physically protect that which you love.
Exactly. And that's, you know, we're
going to segue off of the idea of being
multifaceted in our lives, physical,
mental, spiritual, because that's kind
of how you devoted your entire life.
You're you're an academic. You t you are
focused on the aspect of theology and
Islam's impact on the Christian world.
And so, you've written a number of
books. You have one upcoming, The Two
Swords of Christ. Two Swords of Christ.
So, now tell me a little bit about that
book. Yeah. So, that book's really I
can't really talk about it without
talking about it predecessors because
it's actually it's my trilogy. This is
the third of three and the first would
be sword and scimitar um subtitle which
is necessary to understand is 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
west and that's just a uh you know a
historical outline of the the conflicts
between Islam and Christendom from day
one essentially uh all the way to the
present um and it centers around what I
identified as the eight most decisive
battles which had a profound impact on
the development of the world actually
you know so that book will make clear to
you for example that you know people
think Christendom is Europe and that's
what it became but it wasn't Europe
Christendom was actually North Africa
and the Middle East and Turkey Asia
Minor and Europe and then in one century
almost threequarters of it was actually
enexed and conquered permanently and
other parts later Spain of course was
conquered for centuries and the Balkans
and Anatolia Asia Minor became Turkey um
so that that book really traces that
conflict around the eight most pivotal
battles Then I came up with Defenders of
the West and it's sort of similar you
know it's again very historic but it's
uh this is more of a microcosm and it
centers around biographies. So eight men
I so where I always say whereas sword
and scimitar is about eight decisive
battles defenders of the west is about
eight decisive men okay and so it's this
is more of a you know a book about her
heroism really and this and the great
sacrifices that these Christian men
committed themselves to and it's amazing
when you read about them because who
were they were kings and they were
emperors and they actually sacrificed
everything and died some of them you
know St. Louisie for example who went on
two crusades and uh he wouldn't relent.
So that but the new book uh the two
swords of Christ is actually it's almost
a combination of the two because it's a
long history um like sword and centaur
but it's really homes in on the heroic
aspect. It's about the the military
orders who were, you know, the creme de
la creme of the crusaders and uh
specifically the knights of the temple
and the the knights of the hospital
which templars and hospitalers as
they're known and um you know I just
I've always known about their history
and it's unfortunate especially for the
Templars because they get such a bad rap
in history and just until this very day
the way they're presented and where they
specialize. You watch Kingdom of Heaven,
right? Yeah. Such garbage. The way they
make them appear like they're just these
clowns. Yeah. Yeah.
The way they say Yeah. The way they say
it is like it's just silly. And um you
know even that one guy Reynold Yeah. The
wolf first.
He Well, he's played by that one actor.
Uh he's got like a red beard. He's set.
The Muslims feared him though, right?
They feared him. Well, okay. So in
Kingdom of Heaven, you know, he's
portrayed as a total buffoon who's just
a wararm mongerer and who doesn't keep
his word and he's a total traitor, etc.,
etc. In the books or in the history,
he's actually he wasn't a he wasn't a
member of the military or he was very
close with them and he worked very close
with them. And here's the things that
you don't know. He was in jail. He was
in a Muslim dungeon for like 18 years.
uh he learned Arabic and after he came
out his wish he actually went into Becca
he he he did a a raid uh sailing with
ships and his goal was to actually go
and destroy um the tomb of Muhammad you
know that's and would and and in he was
in other words he was well you would
call today an Islamophobe but times 10
and when they would send him emissaries
uh he would say go ask your Muhammad
about it and so he was very much hated
he's he's depicted in the Islamic
sources as enemies public en Islam's
public enemy number one is how they
portray him. But what you don't know is
um at the at the battle of Hatton where
he actually gets executed um Saladin
according including to the both
Christian and Muslim sources actually
offered him Islam. He said you know
despite all you've done I'll let you
live because you're a good warrior but
embrace Islam. And he actually just
completely professed Christ and said,
"He who you will meet and he he who will
judge you and he who you hate, I profess
his name. I glorify his name." You know,
I and then he just chopped his head off.
So, of course, he's a villain according
to Hollywood. Um, but that's the kind of
um personality that you find in these
guys, the Knights of the Temple and the
hospital. And that's why I wanted to you
know write their history because also
you know there's this question now I
think today amongst uh western American
Christians which is they have a
difficult time reconciling uh force and
violence with faith right there they're
seen as so antithetical and part of the
reason I wanted to write this book I
mean the other books do do it too
defenders of the west but here these
were these were the most pious guys
these were monks who were just devoted
and dedicated uh you know they they They
they took the vows of chastity and
poverty and obedience. Okay, these were
monks but they were also militant
warriors and they were the chief
paragonss of the idea where you know the
verses that they would quote or that
were quoted in their origin talk about
loving your fellow man, loving your you
know and and serving your fellow man. So
the hospitalers for example, it's
amazing what were they? They're actually
older as an organization than the temp
the Templars are the first military
order, but the hospital was before the
temple, but it got militarized later
after the temple. So, they're considered
the second, but they're older. And
what's interesting is when you look at
them, these were guys who, you know,
their their phrase was our lords the
sick. So, all they wanted to do is serve
the sick hospital. Okay? I mean, it was
more like a hospice, but it's the same
idea. and weary travelers and would feed
them and clothe them and and give them
their beds. And isn't it ironic that
that kind of Christian is the one who
became violent? But but but why? Because
they understood that, hey, instead of
always waiting for Muslims to kill
Christians or wound them and then they
come to us and we have to try to heal
them, why don't we nip it in the butt
and actually go and fight the Muslims
and prevent them. So both they and the
Templars um were dedicated to basically
the Templars is the same story. Uh Hugh
of of pines uh a Frenchman, you know, he
he was he was in the first crusade and
he came back and he was just so um upset
seeing that even though Jerusalem had
now been taken over and it was part of
the it was a crusader kingdom, the
pilgrimages for people to get there,
Christians from Europe, they would still
get attacked and killed by Muslims. So
his idea was you know what we're going
to we have to create a unit of guard to
guard Christians who are coming to
pilgrimage and it was for about a decade
it was just him and eight other guys
eight nights you know and then
eventually they got recognized as an
order etc. And um so it's just funny
that you know the Christians that became
the most violent were the most pious. So
and they had no conflict in their mind
that there this is why I think the
conflict today is actually um it's not
because Christianity was always like
this. I think today this idea has been
fed into Christians that you have to be
a dormant and if you're not you're not a
good Christian. Well and I think that
comes from a lot of misunderstanding of
Christian history. They think because
I've read some uh books and everything
where they say that you have a lot of
the pacifist Christians who say that
because of emperor Constantine,
Christianity became militarized. And you
have to look back and be and realize
that Christians were being persecuted
left, right, and center. And so they
weren't part of the state. So they had
no legal authority to be in the
military. And if they were found out,
they were martyed. Uh but there were
people in the military who were
Christians and they were found out and
executed for that and often times you
know the the ones who were executed you
know their executioners would convert
and then they I mean St. George is a
warrior uh Varius um there's so many of
them James Maramorus St. James the the
the war slayer and the the I think he's
James the elder or the greater. Um and
uh he's he's the patron saint of Spain.
And what is he? He's a warrior. Okay. So
um and again you know this here's the
problem with modern day Christians is
they just don't understand the concept
of just war which is yeah Christ is not
about you go attack and conquer but he's
all for defending that which is right
and good. That's what these guys did.
And it comes out in the Bible. You know
think about it. What does Jesus do when
when he performs a miracle for someone?
It's always repent, right? Uh whoever it
is, you're okay. I healed you. Now go
repent. But then a centurion comes and
uh he heals a servant. And what's a
centurion? This man's in charge of a lot
of bloodletting. Did Jesus say, "Hey,
time for you to get out of the
military." He didn't. And you would
think that would have been a big call to
repentance. Yes. But it was it was
understood that you know violence is
sometimes necessary uh including you
know to run a state or same thing with
St. John and these are the verses or the
aspects that people like Augustine would
point to is uh when St. John when
soldiers came to him and St. John the
Baptist sorry um would uh basically also
tell people to repent as he baptized him
and the soldiers asked him what must we
do and he said be content with your
wages. So again, he's he too is
affirming that you could be in the
military and he didn't say anything
about quitting, right? So it's, you
know, I think and here's the other point
that I think is very interesting. I'm
wondering to what extent now that the
idea that turn the other cheek has kind
of taken its whole life and it's become
it's like to be to many Christians
Christ their Christianity begins and
ends with turning the other cheek and
being a doormat and not judging and not
confronting. And I'm wondering, you
know, is that because you're following,
you really want to follow Jesus's words
or are you a coward and you've found a
pretext to justify? So, I want to hear
your thoughts on this because my theory
is uh the reason why this has come about
is because of this ridiculous ridiculous
notion of separation of church and state
because we are no longer able to
officially integrate our faith into our
secular life. whether that be in
politics, whether you know you're a cop,
a military soldier, whatever, uh you
know, we're not allowed to officially
integrate that in. So some people they
decide, okay, I'm either going to
exercise my faith or I'm either going to
exercise my secular vocation and there
can be no overlap and that's kind of why
divorce definitely um this idea of the
separation, you know, before that you
had Christendom and so it wasn't the
idea was it's It's been so
compartmentalized, you know, and it's
like it's and and I would even argue
worse. It's become such an abstract
idea. Christianity, especially in the
West, um that, you know, it's it's now
just nothing but John 3:16, right? Uh
God so loved the world, he gave his only
son and that whoever believes in him
will have and that's it. So, okay, I
believe in Jesus and now I live a
perfectly secular life and I'm saved.
And it's just like that would have been
so bizarre to people in the premodern
and medieval era and even earlier, you
know. So I think it's it's time for
Christians to man up. And um and I I
mean there's a lot of manly and good
Christians who are not cowards, but I'm
just saying I think it's the Western
society has so browbeaten men and
emasculated them and you know taught
them to become as passive and as
possible. And then you you know you get
the the heresy essentially of convincing
them that that's what God wants of you.
And you know I saw I've mentioned it
before but I don't know if you remember
there was a Super Bowl commercial and uh
maybe two years ago and the whole
commercial was just there was no talking
and it was just images of one person
washing another person's foot. Okay. And
but there was a political message in it
because everyone who was on their knees
washing was like a white man or white
woman. Mhm. who looks like a traditional
maybe Christian and everyone sitting was
the opposite. It was a homosexual man, a
Muslim man, um like a a Mexican I guess
immigrant and and then it ends up by
saying, you know, Jesus didn't preach
hate, he washed feet. So, you can see
how I mean, if I'm an enemy of
Christianity, I would love that message
to spread. I would do everything and I
would spend millions to get that message
and then Christians think that is my
faith. That is what I have to do. But
you're actually being disarmed, you're
being emasculated, you're being weakened
by those who want to make sure you never
oppose them and their agendas. Yeah. And
uh and then and then because there has
been so much emasculation, like I said,
then it's doubly worse with Christians
because then they feel not only am I I
don't want to confront people, I don't
want to judge, and I don't want and I'm
going to let evil get a pass and I'm
going to pat myself on the shoulder
about it because that's what Jesus
wants. Okay? And so I think it's time
for Christians to grow up and move on
and and bringing it back to the book.
That's what you'll find. You'll find
these guys who were way more pious than
many Christians of today and who, you
know, they they let their swords do
their talking for them because they were
defending. They they put their lives on
the line. Many of them, the masters of
the temple, I have a statistic and the
hospital, I think like almost half died
in battle. You know, think about that.
Um, so it's just and it's so it's so
alien I think not only to modern men but
to especially western Christian men to
see that and I think it's also going to
be refreshing to see that and and
understand that hey that's part of your
heritage. You know that's how it was for
centuries. That's who you can look up to
not you know whatever Hollywood wants
you to look up to which is whatever is
depraved and dumb and woke. Okay. And
and I think that's what they fear. I
think there's such a resonance that when
people read about these true heroes that
they gravitate towards that and I think
the same powers that want to make sure
Christians believe their job is to be
doormats don't want them to see that
don't want them to know about that and
will do everything to convince them that
those were horrible evil Christians. You
don't want to be like that because it's
so appealing intrinsically to men. So
what there will be a there are a lot of
young men out there that I've met where
they do admire these uh pious uh you
know Christian warriors the people who
fought and protected uh but they they
almost seem to they want to have the
tough guy image but not put in the
either the work or include the piety
with that. Have you noticed any of that?
Oh course you know it's it's the
shortcut. Everyone wants the easy way.
You know they want to they want to be
that but they don't. And and uh and I
think that's what becomes um you know,
we were talking a little bit about that.
That's the that's what toxic masculinity
is because it's not real masculinity.
It's not earned. You have to earn it.
You can't just like uh it's not going to
come from a bottle or a pill, okay?
Being a man, right? It takes work. It
takes sacrifice. And uh if you don't put
the work, then that's when it becomes
fake and exaggerated and toxic
masculinity. It's not attractive. It's
it's force. It's effective. Yeah. See, I
always kind of equated in my mind with
my military and law enforcement
background is that, you know, you have
the guys who get into it for the power,
you know, they want to either, you know,
throw their weight around or they get
into it because they, you know, if it's
the military, they want their education
paid for, or they genuinely want to
protect. And I think, you know, if you
go in there with the intention of I'm
doing this in service to my fellow man
and to honor God, then that kind of
orchestrates how you conduct your life.
Y that's chivalry. Yeah. That that is
it. That's that's what chivalry was.
Chivalry wasn't, you know, you go to a
woman and throw your coat on a puddle.
Uh it was actually that which a woman
would have appreciated a million times
more obviously, which is stepping up and
being a man. Um you know, often times I
hear I'm by no stretch of the
imagination of feminists or or approve
of that sort of thing. But I a lot of
guys today attack women and say, "Oh,
feminism ruined everything." And and and
yeah, I agree with that. But guess what?
You let it happen. Yeah. women are the
way they are because they're a
reflection of what men are. And uh well,
you see it in the classic TV shows. You
know, the men, they come home from work,
they put on the the TV, they don't
interact with their family. And if I was
a woman, I wouldn't want to have that
kind of marriage either, you know,
because men kind of got away from the
idea of that it's a partnership. You do
things together. It's like, yes, the the
wife cares for the home, but you as a
band, you also have to instruct your
children. You have to be a part of their
lives, and you have obligations to each
other, right? And it's not about sitting
and playing video games. Even if the
video games, the Templars. Exactly.
Yeah. There's a lot of people who kind
of get into the fantasy elements of it.
You have a lot of people who like they
enjoy role playing uh tabletop games.
And it's like I don't have a problem
with that or video games, but going back
to what we said earlier, balance. You
know, you can have your uh blowoff steam
hobby, but at the end of the day, you
have to use that as inspiration to be
like, "Okay, I've seen what hurt her
arrows looks like in this sense, whether
it's reading a book, playing a video
game, and watching a movie. Now, let's
go out and do it." Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
And uh that and that's that's again part
of you know the new generation and the
culture which is everything is the
phone. You know I just sit in my room
and I look at my phone and you know
that's my outlet to reality and it's
kind of like uh yeah there there's a lot
of work that needs to be done for
western man to uh but I think he can do
it. Um and the models are there and it's
happened before. The pre the pre the
precedent is there and it's just
everything is kind of set up against
men. Uh but you've got to rise above it.
You can't and you can't conform to it
and and you can't just sit and blame and
point fingers, oh it's because women,
it's because feminism. It's because of
you that feminism came about. If it
wasn't for you, they wouldn't be there,
you know. So why the two swords of
Christ? What is the significance of
that?
Mhm.
Well, for the new book, The Two Swords
of Christ, I chose that because in their
origin and in their inception, the
Templars and later the hospitalers and
all the military orders, one of the
verses that was uh biblical verses that
really um you know spoke to them was the
ver the famous verse which is um you
know Jesus says go sell your shirt and
buy a sword. And the disciples say look
Lord here are two swords and he says
that is enough. And of course, now
here's a perfect example. Modern day
Christians have allegorized this verse
into meaninglessness. Means nothing now,
right? It's nothing. You might as well
have said nothing. Okay? Because it's
gladly not definitely not a sword. But
but how preodern Christians and
especially medieval Christians, the
majority of them understood that verse
was that we as Christians have two
enemies. We have spiritual enemies and
we have material secular enemies. And we
have two different swords. we have a
spiritual sword and we have a physical
sword to fight both evils and that's why
they're they were and are enough. Okay,
so that's how they understood it. So
that's why I chose that um for the for
the title for the book. But I also upon
reflection and this this is coincidental
um I realized I was writing about two
military orders, the Templars and the
Hospitalers. And so in a way it's
precisely because they believed in that
they became the two swords of Christ,
right? Yes. And uh another uh verse I
think people misconstrue is when our
Lord tells Peter, if you live by the
sword, you die by the sword. Because to
me that ser that more symbolizes because
Peter's role was to be you know priest
you know you know priest prophet you
know guiding spiritually. His role
wasn't to be in the secular realm of
doing war. But there is a role for that.
Yeah, it look you know what look let's
let's take this turning the other cheek
to its logical conclusion if we may okay
so all right I I slap you and you you
forgive me okay okay that's great right
but now what if uh and you know what if
someone enters your house you're a
Christian man and some a group comes in
and they start raping your wife and
children and they they kill them
afterwards are you going to turn the
other are you going to sit there and do
nothing absolutely not do you think
that's what Jesus would If Jesus was
there, would he be like, "No, no, no.
Put your sword down. Let him finish." Do
you really think that's the message?
Yeah. Because Jesus's role was to die
for our sin. So, of course, hey, Peter,
lay down this you're mission. Yeah.
You're getting in the way of that
mission. But we are all called to
protect our family. But I mean, if you
take it to this logical conclusion, and
so I I I imagine a lot of Christians
listening to me will say, "Yeah, yeah,
no. In that case, we would fight back."
So, now I wonder, so, okay, what's
what's the draw? What's the line? You
know, is it is it just this extreme
horrific example I gave you that you can
fight back or what, you know, how far
can we go? So, it's to me and you know,
Christians historically had no problem
with just war, just violence, which is
I'm Hey, defense. It's the same thing
with capital punishment, execution.
There was nothing uncchristian about
that. You're a murderer, that's the
judgment that you get. Okay? And it's
just like I told you this idea that we
have to be doormats or we're not
Christians is is so like it's so it just
completely has metastasized amongst
especially western Christians. And again
it compliments I think they're
pre-existing cowardice. So they're just
making a virtue of a vice saying you
know what I I don't want to be
confrontational. I don't want to judge.
I don't want to say I don't want to I
don't want to stand against evil. But
that's because that's what Jesus wants.
And yeah, that's I'm sure that's
comforting, but you're wrong. Yeah, it
reminds me of that meme where, you know,
you have this uh billboard that the
vegans put out and they're like they
have this row of animals and they're
like, "Where do you draw the line for
what you eat?" And they put just put it
Yeah. Right there.
Yeah. And it's just unfortunate, you
know, that because the material is
there. See, I'm not here to say
Christianity is a warlike religion. Of
course, Jesus taught love and
forgiveness and tolerance and all that.
I get that. But you know what? There's a
fine line, you know, where especially,
you know, most of the theologians would
have told you it was a personal thing.
So, yeah, I can forgive you, but the
state has to have rules. It has to have
physical enforcement, necessary
violence, war. Yes. Okay. To preserve
the the peace. Otherwise, you're you're
facilitating evil and like I said,
making a virtual vice, saying you're the
good guy because you're really a coward.
Yeah. I think what a lot of people don't
understand is that the ancient world was
a very barbaric place. You know, you had
people you had uh human sacrifice, you
had cannibalism,
uh rampant sexuality where there was no
uh respect for, you know, whoever you
married, if they even had the concept of
marriage. And so, you know, what our
Lord, you know, came into the world to
do, one of save us from our sins, but
what are our sins? And it's this anim
animalistic uh you know kill or be
killed you know uh fighting for power
money pleasure and it comes our war
comes in to temper that and put it into
its proper place where you know uh you
know violence for the sake of profit
becomes justice where we govern our
people and protect them and that's what
the masculine Christian state looks like
if t if taken to its proper conclusion
balance it's balance you know and uh if
you go one way or the If if you're all
militant, that's bad. If you're all
passive, that's bad, you know, and
people need to use their heads a little
bit. And uh yeah, so you know, when it
comes again to this to this book in
particular, I think hopefully it might
inspire people and open their eyes as as
to, you know, these guys were it's
amazing how like religiously pious. And
I'm sure people will dismiss, oh, but
they were, you know, Catholic monks.
What do they really know? You know,
maybe they weren't saved, you know, but
but um you know, well, all they had to
do is proclaim Christ, right? Yeah. they
can live however. These guys actually
did more cuz they're I don't know. I
don't know what they were thinking. You
know, they could have just like just
said a few words and lived their life.
But in your book, do you go into their
routines or anything? What a typical
what did a typical day? Well, they were
essentially when not at war. Okay. Which
was often the case. They were living
like monks. They were like uh they they
they kept the the all the prayer times.
They fasted. And it's funny because in
some of their treatises, they're
actually warned not to fast too much.
And uh James of Vitri who was I think a
bishop uh after some he knew the
templars and he was in the holy land
bishop of some area but anyway um he
actually chastised them because some of
them would fast so much that when they
would fight they couldn't even fight.
Yeah. You know so he was like no you
guys have to be able to eat meat and
most of their diet was actually mostly
it was it was a rather carnivore type
diet actually. They would eat a lot of
meat and milk, uh, cheese, that was the,
you know, there and of course whatever
vegetables and bread, but um, and they,
but that otherwise they would be
training and fighting in combat. I mean,
talk about a veal lifestyle. Morning to
night, you're either on your hands and
knees praying or you're fasting or
you're battling for God. And these are
the guys that today's Christians point
at and go, "Oh, you're not a real
Christian." Let's not call you. Oh,
absolutely. especially as a Catholic
myself. I know you're not, but it's
amazing that you can still have that
respect for their way of life and how
they conducted themselves. I had one
friend fairly recently, uh, God help
her. Uh, you know, I I was explaining to
her that I still do the tradition of
year round not eating meat on Fridays
and she uh just from the other room
because I was talking with my best
friend, her husband about this and uh
from the other room I just hear Jesus
never said to do that.
And I was just like, don't get in no
argument.
But it's just like there's a lot of
things that Jesus says to didn't say to
do or not do. And I I think that's
another aspect that a lot of Christians
miss is that whatever however you live
your life. Um if you're doing it
virtuously, you know, you're if you're
doing it in service to God, then you're
doing what what he told you to do. you
know, whether it's academically, you
know, I'm going to write all these
books, whether it's coming to speak to
your congressman, your senator, whatever
that looks like, you know, so long as
you're doing it out of love for neighbor
and love for God, you are doing what our
Lord told you to do. It it doesn't have
to be specifically written down. It says
that, you know, when our Lord returned
after his crucifixion that he told him
so many things that it couldn't all the
books in the world couldn't contain it.
So are you supposed to tell me that what
uh the apostles passed down uh to their
disciples on down the line to where we
are today that what they were told and
how they built the church life those are
at odds with each other. Well that's
that's the uh that's the the modern day
rendition you know it's so um I I just
you know I don't understand for a
Christian to think that it's you know
it's been so turned into an abstract
idea you know it's like I just have to
believe in a story. Okay, that Jesus God
manifested, came crucified, resurrected,
and therefore I am now saved and uh I
don't really have to do anything and you
better not do anything because that's
works. Oh, how dare you do a good deed?
You're trying to earn your salvation.
It's like come on, man. Like that's what
Jesus that's what do something, you
know, about the book of James, you know?
So with your so I'm supposed to go out
there just do the most depraved things
because because I put my trust in God.
his mercy so right that I can murder you
right here right now. But then you feel
bad about it and you're forgiven, right?
But but if you try to do good stuff, oh,
heaven forbid because you're earning it.
I just want to do good stuff because God
commanded me to do it. I'm not wor I'm
not doing it to be saved. I'm doing it
because that's what I was told to do.
It's part of living out the life of
Christ, following these are the first
Christians were called followers of the
way. And so it was a path. Yeah. It was
a path you followed and how you conduct
your life. And the more you integrate
your faith into what you do daytoday,
the better your life becomes. You're
able to handle adversity better. You're
able to do greater uh more courageous
works. And a lot of that comes down to
admittedly there have been a lot of
abuses in the Catholic Church. You know,
the selling of indulgences and you know,
I imagine at the time they tried to
justify it's like, okay, we need to
raise all this money to support uh
persecuted communities. They're thinking
they were trying to think strategically
very short term. They're not thinking
the uh the impact that could have. And
so now we have this idea that
indulgences themselves aren't bad when
really it's just a matter of how I'd
conduct my life if I do it prayerfully
through fasting, giving of balms. Like
I'm not trying to buy my way. I'm trying
to uh the it's the church telling you,
hey, what does it look like to be a good
Christian? It means protecting others.
It means uh giving uh some of your money
away to help uh the community. And if
you're not doing that those things, then
you're living selfishly. You know, as I
just mentioned, James, you know, it's
like a lot of people don't want to read
the book of James, you know, and uh and
it's like it's just don't get hung up
about the idea of salvation. Just do
what you're told, which is be a good
person. Action. It's action. It's not
just sitting and bickering about ex
Jesus. I don't think that's what, you
know, Jesus Christ came to do.
Well, thank you Raymond for uh taking
this time to speak with All right. Why
don't you try that?
[Music]